it's roberto clemente those from puerto
rico and those who are clemente award
winners and nominees this year are given
the option to wear number 21.
miguel he's done his best work here at
citi field nine starts three and one
with a
3.80 tyler o'neal with runners at second
and third and nobody out for the
cardinals here in the top of the first
on three and oh it's a base head into
the gap and left center all the way to
the wall o'neill to second two runs will
score two nothing cardinals here in the
first nothing into the count on dylan
carlson
and carlson a base hit into left a two
out single brings in o'neal three
nothing red birds here in the top of the
first and runners at the corners for the
redbirds
shallow center
and this will drop
a run will score what about two yes
sosa in there all the way from first
hustling and scoring and vader loving it
five nothing cardinals
as lester strikes out to finally put a
close to the inning five run inning in
the first the most the cardinals have
had since scoring six in the first on
opening day in cincinnati leicester has
gone eight in one lifetime against the
mets starting for the 12th time in his
career the pitch to lindor he swings and
misses a fast ball up
ground out strikeout
he's been striking out a lot more than i
thought he would six times in the first
two games
and he goes down swinging that time on a
change up from mcgill second strikeout
for tyler one two coming to a kneel and
the change up in there for a call for it
strike
so one two three inning for mcgill with
a couple of strikeouts thrown in
five-nothing cardinals in the second
pete snapped it over 20 with a double
his last time up in the 11th inning last
night
and he snatched this one to deep left
field coming our way and that ball is
out of here
it alonso with his 33rd home run of the
year against the mets on the board
i think he was taking taking aim with us
boys that's all right
all night long
it's very weird looking at the ball on
flight from this angle
the last time we sat out here was two
years ago for that game against
washington when todd frazier had one
just inside the left field foul fall to
tie it up against doolittle that was
conforto's first walk off
and now pete hits one over our heads
mccann with a fly ball into shallow left
oh what a play by sosa with his back to
the infield two outs runner on second
base has lindor
bats pulled down the ground
and off sosa mcneil turns third he'll
come in to score
so sosa after making a great play in the
last inning boots this one and the mets
creep a little closer it's five to two
that'll be an error on sosa bringing in
mcneal
it's almost like he over shuffled he
didn't he didn't get himself in good
position kind of overran it there a
little bit sort of sidled over a little
better and he just booted it and vader
had a big hit he was able to protected a
ball in the center field it was a high
fly ball really off the end of the bet
bader hits it out two deep left field at
the wall gone
hanging breaking ball
harrison bader with home run number 12.
and bader has brought in three tonight
see it just spinning
never good when the catcher reaches back
over the plate it's like they say
nothing good happens after midnight
nothing good happens when the catcher
has to reach back over the plate when
he's sitting outside
miguel castro pitched in the opening
game of the series on monday night back
for more tonight yeah a couple
strikeouts in any one hit but no runs
allowed
and mundo associates one right at
lendore
press in camera work again high throw
but alonso stays with it halfway through
first and second nobody out for the mets
in their half of the fifth it's vr who's
grounded out to third and also popped
out over two
we are bunting here
yachty hops on it and out at first
what a play wow
what a play yada year molina mets are
going to get the attention of the
umpiring crew and take a look at it this
is going to be really close and
wow is the heel at the bag is the ball
in the glove this is as close as it gets
you can understand why you challenge
here you're down 6-2 with big bads
coming up that is just one heck of a
play that is a tough play javier baez is
all for two against lester tonight but
with one swing you can make it a one-run
ball game yeah he can
into center bader back near the wall he
has it baez gave it a ride and it stays
in the ballpark in the catch made by
harrison bader into the bottom of the
sixth lester will get pete alonso to
lead it off
tied him up and struck him out similar
pitch to alonso to strike him out back
in the fourth seven strikeouts for
leicester that matches his season high
lester's still cruising here and now
kevin pallar will bat
fly ball by pillar deep left field
headed over our heads and that ball is
out of here
kevin pillor with his 15th home run of
the year to get the mets a little closer
it's now six to three top of the seventh
inning it'll be goldschmidt
and we may get one here
in the deep left
at the wall gone
paul goldschmidt home run number 26
7
3.
st louis
26 home runs for goldie
oh it's interesting it's
fastball strike and then automatic
0-1 slider that didn't move again and
you know what he was looking slider and
he got it wow nolan arnado
auronado high drive down the left-field
line it is gone
nolan arenado with home run number 32
and he's driven in
98 this year this is another hangar
that just rolled up there first pitch
too
i mean you just threw a fastball six
inches off the plate for a strike i
think i'd go back out there 32 home runs
now for nolan oronato well 37 year old
john lester relieved by 36 year old
andrew miller
barraza hits one out to right center
that's going to fall for a base hit that
will bring in mcneal
so peraza with his first at bat in
nearly two months dumps the single into
right centered and driving a run and the
mets creep back again it's now eight to
four runners at first and third two outs
and mcfarland has gotten two batters out
in a row here and now he's got to get
pete alonso
and alonso hits it out to deep right
newt bar back
and has it large newt barr with the
catch and he robs alonzo he took a home
run away from alonso and three mick runs
as well what a play by
newt barr in right field oh my goodness
has the cardinals defense been terrific
in this series high fives all the way
around for the rookie and he is pumped
up and bringing in the pitch for the
mets he'll get sosa 3-2 pitch
and sosa hits a high-fly ball into the
gap in right center and go on
and mundo sosa in opposite field home
run his sixth of the year and mundo sosa
showing off all the skills tonight so
the cardinals not done yet
and goldie hits it the other way against
the shift and here comes tommy edmond to
score
goldie is a triple away from the cycle
and he now has driven in 86 and the
cardinals extend their lead to 10 to
four the one-two
orinato hits it the other way base hit
goldschmidt will score
orinato
now at 99
runs batted in in his first season with
st louis here's michael conforto a
single and forward bats the 02
ground ball
so some
it's a three-game sweep at citi field
the cardinals win it 11-4
[Music]